get ready we're about to enter the age
of autonomous vehicles the new Google
car drives itself you heard that right
Google the internet company Ford will be
mass producing vehicles with full
autonomy within five years in 2019 by
2020 it's happening today it is self
driven it is not a concept it is a
production vehicle and we have it here
with us today it's just can no one's
close profitable Robo taxi is still a
decade away George Hotz is the 30 year
old hacker / entrepreneur best known as
the first person to jailbreak the
original iPhone when he was 17 after
dropping out of college Hots did short
stints at Facebook and Google but didn't
fit in with Silicon Valley culture in
2015
hot started comma AI a company that
sought to up n what he views as big tax
wasteful and short-sighted approach to
self-driving vehicles they're designed
in a way that would only make sense if
they're gonna be fully autonomous
sensors cameras compute remote
assistance operators fleet managers
lame-o must map every inch of every
Street it's gonna travel instead of
building specialized cars that rely on
expensive sensors and follow laser
mapped routes comma AI has created an
autonomous driving system that runs on a
smartphone works on most vehicles sold
in America and requires no additional
hardware this wire is the only thing
that connects it to the car it uses the
phone's cameras and taps into the
built-in radar and drive-by-wire systems
in cars built after 2012 automatically
turning the steering wheel and operating
the gas and brakes most self-driving
cars in the world in five years will
become an AI so you basically want
everybody who's watching this to be able
to turn their car into a self dress car
in five years when I first spoke with
Hots he predicted that by 2020 cars
would take their own wheels for large
stretches without humans paying
attention or what's known as level 3
autonomy and that by 2022 they would
achieve level 4 or full self-driving
ability in limited areas now it steers
on how those predictions sort of panned
out
none of that's true every single car
today needs somebody paying attention
Tesla us lame-o things got very good on
the highway last year ours very good
auto pods very good there knowing your
level 3 level 4 is mostly a scam and
what do you say that because for example
one of those way more cars costs
$250,000 and they have a full-time
driver monitoring it so I mean that's
not a product that's a precedent well
the whole thing's oppressed them until
the system can be shown to be
statistically safer than a human alone
the driver has to pay attention badge
again but you think that self-driving
cars at level 4 just a scam in general
or just the current offerings I think
that the approach of using HD maps and
building effectively line following
robots which every high-end level for
companies doing way mo zooks cruise its
rebuild a very high definition map we
plot an exact line for the car to drive
and then we just followed that line I
think this whole approach doesn't work
because self-driving is not a new
ability that the world gets it's not
like you know building a rocket do it
Amar's there's nobody get to Mars right
you could have a self-driving car right
now it's called uber right put a person
in it like who cares it's just a cost
question and this whole 250 thousand
dollar car outfitted with lidar s maps
made to one centimeter it just it
doesn't make economic sense so that's
why I think level 4 is a scam but again
these companies have spent so much money
look we spend any point 1 million we
fold we go on there who cares that's not
money we're profitable
zooks guy they raised nine hundred
ninety million they've never made any
revenue and they're running out of money
how do you wake up every day how do you
wake up every day you're just ok with
yourself like that now Hoxha's company
has rolled out its first truly
all-in-one device the nine hundred and
ninety nine dollar comma to mount it to
your windshield plug it into your car's
obd-ii port and commas open pilot
software can operate most cars sold in
America LIGO went out of business we
bought off all the reverb parts this is
a pretty constant foam the comma two
packs a modded smartphone and other
hardware into one slim plastic casing
which hots 3d prints in the garage of
kamas new office in San Diego
like some demo that we've Reitsma
friends this is the actual just version
of the software that's available for
free online right now
and you call yourself the North Korea of
self-driving company yeah I said that in
TechCrunch than that yeah what do you
mean by that that we're not beholden to
anybody else's agenda our goal is to
bring self-driving technology to the
lift platform we control the full
experience from the app to the origin if
all you have is the tech you have a demo
uber is what actually allows you to
commercialize this technology number we
like took a phone we put it into 3d
printer case and it drives cars and how
did you track cars really well we just
we just did that the question isn't
whether self-driving cars are going to
happen or not the question is are they
going to look like a way mo world where
you own absolutely nothing you are just
a consumer or a world where well a whole
lot of diverse decentralized people
contribute to these things the whole
worlds built on an ecosystem of
open-source it's not like a like a
top-down they own you model comma
crowdsources real driving data from
customers to train its algorithms hot
says his holistic vision system doesn't
rely on precise maps or lane markings to
know where to drive it will take you
into the right place through the
intersection this is what I mean how
it's doing a lot more than looking at
lanes it's looking at the road and
saying where would human Drive in this
scenario
unlike previous demos that have been
limited to freeway driving
we tested hots a system on surface
streets and moderate traffic and let it
take the wheel of our 2016 Honda Civic
as we rounded bends and went through
intersections you actually have to brake
earlier than the human would because if
you don't brake earlier than the human
would the human disk ages starts
breaking right why would the magic of a
on hots promised the Kama two would
handle stop signs and red lights on its
own when there was a car in front of us
I'm amazed that how many cars will just
plow right into a stop car
so the radar sees it but it can confuse
it very easily with manhole covers or
with white posts I mean this is one of
usin areas that like no one would think
is challenging right
when I switched to the stock system on
our Honda test car in a similar scenario
the car started accelerating towards the
stopped cars at a light the Kama two
drove on its own for the first four
minutes of the demo note to the wheels
and left engine but then we got an
urgent reminder that humans are still
needed to take over when other humans do
things comma two's front-facing camera
can't see or that hots is AI system can
yet predict well see things like that
lead to disengagement what cars are
behaving according to the rules this
sort of goes to the heart of the
difference between describing something
as self-driving or a driver assist
because this is the we're sort of
getting to the point now where the
technology is advanced enough that
people can start to rely on it because
as we saw in this road test I found
myself sort of starting to drift a
little bit how are you gonna bridge that
gulf where it's we're going from really
advanced driver assistance systems that
people might over rely on and think it's
too good to actually fully self-driving
car driver monitor the driver doesn't
get a choice to not pay attention well
disengage hots is the most important new
feature of the comma to is continuous
driver monitoring the front camera was
replaced by an infrared front camera so
we can do driver monitoring during day
and night it tracks the drivers head
position and eye movements in real-time
to ensure they never get distracted or
lulled into a false sense of security no
matter how trustworthy the system seems
to be so if you're still looking at me
up there you go there's the beep you
better look at the road according to
hots it's a critical feature until fully
self-driving cars are developed you
can't ship a product that makes driving
less safe
the bar is where driving is right now
and I think with driver monitoring you
actually quite exceed that bar because
of a large amount of accidents caused by
distraction other high-end systems
including GM supercruise now also
feature driver monitoring but not
Tesla's which requires drivers to touch
the wheel every few seconds what's the
purpose of having autopilot if you still
have to put your hands on the wheel
because the probability of an accident
with autopilot is just less a pedestrian
in Tempe Arizona was killed last night
by a self driving uber taxi it is
believed to be the first fatality caused
by an autonomous vehicle uber only
adopted driver monitoring after one of
its self-driving prototypes was involved
in a fatal crash despite having a safety
driver behind the wheel I mean I
remember when I realized how important
driver monitoring was I watched the uber
crash a watching of a crash video you
look at it you watch you watch you know
the driver was I was looking down here
you know plaza new pedestrian yeah you
watch that video a few times you're like
yeah we can fix this they added a second
safety driver and technology to monitor
them for distraction let's talk a little
bit about that that uber crash because
that seemed like a pretty easy like
there was a person that was unobstructed
and the vision system just never saw
them right so what happened so first and
foremost the driver wasn't watching
I think the fault stops there and then
they made some distasteful choices in
the code the car was braking for false
positives too much it's like well we got
to turn this down right we're gonna
write this little bit of code which is
like just don't brake for one second and
see if after one second you still want
to have to brake and that's why the car
didn't break that's wasn't the NTSB
report so a very foreseeable verily yeah
there this was not this was not subtle
at all right hots police's open-source
system is more transparent and
accountable to users than closed systems
that tout approval from state regulators
the permit thing seems like one of these
like showboating things almost these
small companies oh we're certified with
the California DMV to test autonomous
vehicles yeah now you have to fill out a
lot more paperwork and like it's unclear
that that stuff is making anything any
more safe
I mean uber had a permit yeah if anybody
had like looked at that code driver
monitoring is great we try really hard
to make it non intrusive it's intrusive
it's open-source software like people
can comment it out and so we kind of
have that like we can't just force
people like we have to offer them
something 2017 when we talked you said
that you never recorded the front-facing
camera as part of a privacy measure but
you've since changed course and now you
do
driver recording so you can optionally
record the camera only about 20% of
people opt in but if you're using driver
monitoring that's not going to our
server storm
it's local on the device you can check
the code you can confirm that in
exchange for being monitored we're not
just selling you a monitoring product
we're selling you uh well uh I can't say
self-driving a self-driving products
we're just gonna say let's just say it
Ieyasu me sue me in 2016 hots aborted
the launch of commas first consumer
self-driving product the comma one after
regulators wrote him a letter outlining
safety concerns and potential compliance
issues to avoid any legal gray area this
time the comma to ships with only
dashcam software pre-installed Hots
offers the open pilot software for free
as an add-on
we don't sell software the software
speech it is free and the user chooses
whatever software they'd like to install
open pilot is an advanced driver
assistance system I will be ready to
take over at any time in terms of how
you're framing the company and the
company's mission right it used to be
you were building self-driving cars now
it seems like you're framing it more in
terms of advanced driver assistance so
maybe maybe we said stuff with a little
more hype my distaste for hype has grown
immensely in the last two-and-a-half
years it was always really the same
thing is it in response to regulators
like really being touchy about that
particular language like self-drive it
doesn't matter people know how good it
is you can watch videos on YouTube a
hundred miles driving hands-free and
then you like look in your language this
is just a user of the product and
there's a hundred more videos just like
it all the lawyers and the regulators
they hate terms like that you know what
take your terms man take your terms
safety especially after the headlines
made by that tragic death in Phoenix
yeah so safeties and this isn't a cliche
thing but it's all about safety for us
cybersecurity was considered from the
very beginning it uses our purpose-built
sensors and compute systems to deliver
superhuman performance
superhuman preceptory powers superhuman
levels of safety hots reject suggestions
that his system is any less safe than
those of his competitors because it runs
on a phone we've driven over ten million
miles now no injuries no fatalities like
right I won't sell safety right our
slogans are like make driving chill and
ghost riding for the masses and actually
I think that marketing safety and actual
safety or opposite things right the more
you tell something that something is
safe the less care they're gonna they're
gonna take with that
but that's the world today where where
you have companies saying we have
space-age safety and people like that's
a company who cares about safety
you know , I will do ruining it it would
I just you know the people they don't
they don't look they don't critically
think so one of the big concerns with
your system that I've seen based on our
initial conversation is that people
think that this is gonna get hacked
right they they see a phone they say
okay somebody's gonna hack into this I
don't want that in my car what's your
response to that where are all these bad
people where are all these hackers right
hackers are just there they're come
hackers are practically made up to sell
security [ __ ] the whole like sure at
a state level the states are all hacking
each other corporate espionage sure
individuals hacking you to crash your
car that doesn't exist nobody cares if
an intelligence agency if a major state
wants you dead you don't have any chance
it doesn't matter oh well I keep my
Linux kernel up-to-date by compiling the
latest I have Arch Linux ok that's not
how they're coming to get you bro
guys we're close to cracking that human
performance barrier and reaching
superhuman territory superhuman a
superhuman superhuman oh this whole
space is extremely disappointed why the
whole space disappointing there is no
way for your average person to
distinguish between hype and reality I
mean at least our stuff is like cool new
abilities you get for your car we're at
CES and people are shocked people are
like wait no way that's what it does
is that is that possible I met up with
Hots at the Airbnb camera rented off the
Las Vegas Strip during CES the largest
consumer electronics show in the world
oh yeah it's typically a place where
exciting new tech is revealed for the
first time and autonomous vehicles have
featured prominently the past few years
BMW for GM Nissan VW and Volvo say
they're gonna have autonomous cars on
the road in three years the elevat--
team is willing to say that we'll see
flying taxis by 2023 this year was no
exception but hot says the automated
vehicle industry has adopted what he
views as the Silicon Valley approach
focusing on growth and hype rather than
delivering truly innovative products see
much before that we're at CES and that
people are sort of amazed
by the technology even here but you've
always said that self-driving is not
really your main concern it's just the
coolest application of AI and you want
to solve AI right have you seen anything
here given that this is the the biggest
consumer electronics show in the world
that is sort of an interesting
application or that has given you new
ideas about where you're going I used to
read the CES headlines and like all this
like new cool stuff coming out what new
came out this year there's three
convention halls packed with stuff that
people say suite convention halls packed
with businesses trying to participate in
this kind of scam economy
show me something where it's like I can
pay them money and get some new ability
right for years this happened , to is a
new cool ability that you have
what else did CES is like that it's not
it's just ads do you think there's a
sort of fundamental misunderstanding or
a malfunction in the way that the
technology market is working that's
leading to this state of affairs the
whole ecosystem doesn't understand they
got funding from somebody maybe they're
selling to another biz dev person and
another company who knows how these
corporate sales processes work so
someone came up to me yesterday and
they're trying to we do data labeling
for AI do you need data labeling in your
company and they're just so far off the
mark because it would take me more time
to integrate whatever it is they have
than to just build whatever it is they
have well write that into ours and react
like what is that why does that company
exist last time we talked to you were
complete optimist about the future was
all that you know AI simulations you're
going into you look forward to slaying
virtual dragon beasts and your holodeck
you know so you see much you can see
much less optimistic this time I'm an
optimist for the long-term future on a
retired in virtual reality with way it's
my girlfriend no I want all these things
to happen and if these things are going
to happen we need to change culture I
tried it with the company and like
doesn't work I all said it's not like I
started comedy I with the explicit
intent of changing culture do you have a
path to what type of entity or
organization would actually be effective
and in this regard maybe it's like
trying to fight for free speech by
suppressing ideas you can't do it right
if I'm like gonna take the corporate
machinery in the corporate language and
try to fight against that
I don't know if I can't isn't the whole
point sort of though of companies is
that like once you get these lethargic
incumbents that have just become
sclerotic and don't innovate anymore
then that's when you get you know that's
Microsoft then you got Google right
Google then you know now Amazon is
rising like now Amazon you know so why
don't you think that that's a good
structure it's probably true it's just
hard to live through people occasionally
give arguments that like oh we're and
and we're in an unprecedented you know
degree of corporate control you don't
understand
Google just buys any startup that might
remotely compete with them Facebook owns
all the other social networks there's
absolute monopolies there's no way these
companies are ever going to be taken
down it's different this time they said
about IBM and the nineties right in
reality it's not different they ruined
it but everything gets ruined and that's
just what it is and the next thing is
gonna be cool and maybe this is gonna be
a good decade this is gonna be the
decade of like decentralization like
real decentralization not not scam
crypto I see us but we start to build
systems that are structurally incapable
of red seeking where anybody can can
fork in and make it better I don't know
I don't know what this looks like and
you actually proposed that like you
wanted to start a religion cuz you think
that's a better way to get at this sort
of society moving towards the
resurrection it turns out that when you
say you're gonna start a religion you
get emails from a whole lot of crackpots
I'm not starting religion the religion
the religions over so this is a weird
talk you don't think if God is a wizard
think of God as a computer programmer
because that's probably much more likely
who created the worlds in our world
computer programmers so what does God
that's probably computer program at
South by I wasn't actually advocating
that we try to jailbreak the simulation
it's more of a paradigm for thinking
about us as all together and we should
look up and not across you in this South
by Southwest talk that you gave last
year you were arguing that reality is an
AI simulation whether you were doing
this to troll the audience or not is a
different question but can you just give
us that that the short version of that
argument we're gonna build simulations
and well if we're gonna build
simulations there's one of us and we're
gonna build with millions of simulations
just statistically well take the total
number of war
in existence and you're much more likely
in a simulated world than a non
simulated world a lot of people accept
that or at least a lot people heard
about it what I wanted people to think
about is maybe there's actually right
out of the simulation the best analogy I
gave was like if you're Mario inside of
Mario World can you get out and you can
there's exploits in Mario you could
imagine Mario actually taking the Super
Mario Brothers source code may be
written to see may be written assembly
and looking through it right well first
you can do a lot of really cool stuff
with in the world like dude there's a
warp whistle in world 3 behind the white
block right so you can start with that
like the cool stuff that you can just do
in this world and then you can start
thinking about exploits all right which
can get you into the processor of the
Nintendo and then you can get out on the
internet you can you know take over a
robot in the real world right and hack
someone's car
watch out Mary I was coming for you guys
you also said in that talk that we could
start running experiments to start to
come closer to seeing what these
exploits are or where you know the
limits of reality are what does that
look like how do you do an experiment to
see if reality is reality in a way this
isn't any different from mainstream
science and technology look man you know
if you uh if you if you arrange if
you're in silicon atoms like this and
you dope them you can you can get
semiconductors then you can put them on
chips and get lots of semiconductor you
know computers those are just cool
exploits in reality so you view
technology really as a way to explore
nature yeah in a lot of ways yeah so
we're just discovering what the rules of
the world actually are yeah and I think
that's forgotten by a lot of people who
I think Silicon Valley and Technology
are not synonymous Silicon Valley
culture needs to die and technology will
live on if I can get you to make a few
more predictions where do you think that
that comma will be or self-driving cars
in the next two to five years I hope
that the reckoning will finally come for
these level for companies that have now
spent billions of dollars and made zero
dollars in revenue and have no possible
path to revenue they're trying to become
ride-sharing companies uber and lyft IP
owned and they're not doing well those
are not profitable companies
and this is what you're gonna copy I'll
protect you maybe this is me being
optimistic but those companies well
serious downturns layoffs mergers back
into the parent corporation but you know
Cruz becomes GM weight becomes Google
zooks just sorry sorry everybody sorry
the dreams that Tesla comma mobile I I
think we'll see almost commutes where
you don't have a disengagement kind of
be the norm but still paying attention
at all times when Zook screws and lame-o
start to really falter things are gonna
look good for us and then you want to
buy comment I I have a price I'll sell
out 1 billion dollars for a billion a
lot of things are negotiable I could do
a lot of stuff at the billion that's a
good endowment for our religion